about one minute ago according to our
time the interview have you heard about
the interview this little film that's
upsetting the people in North Korea uh
it apparently debuted on YouTube you can
download it or stream it for apparently
six bucks and it has become pretty
obvious to me that this is the biggest
and best publicity stunt
of all time so I want to start with our
movie man is was this whole thing not a
setup no no wasn't a setup but there's a
tremendous amount of of dishonesty in it
and and just you should always look at
what powerful people say with a careful
eye the the president of Sony
Entertainment who said after Obama's
press conference when the president said
Sony should have released it and he went
the theaters the theaters pulled the
movie what was I supposed to do and
someone was like well you what about on
the end we don't have a way to do that
what we don't know what we did
personally he didn't just apologize he
said essentially we stood firm we did
not back down we were ready to fight and
stand up for freedom
you really wanna release the movie on
the Internet well yeah and by the way
for the record he Sony which owns
PlayStation right is a streaming service
and I'm pretty sure they own crackle -
are there somehow managed to figure out
how to get it on YouTube yeah I guess
what it just like initially Sony it
called YouTube and YouTube would take
their calls I'm pretty sure that if Sony
one of this movie out they could have
had it out and then of course they also
didn't do the other thing in their
principled standing up yeah which was
called theaters back and say please
don't
or call smaller theaters or make any
attempt whatsoever obviously they were
very comfortable pulling the movie but
no I don't think it was a son it
didn't it didn't need a publicity stunt
it's fraught with gigantic peril so if
it's not a publicity stunt though
doesn't the threat still stand the idea
that uh you know the hackers said we're
gonna do some kind of night like that
still stands right I mean if you freaked
out about every anonymous threat that
was issued online then everyone would be
in a constant state of panic yeah right
after the show right right I mean I'm
getting 12 bit terroristic threats right
now as I speak right so I never really
thought that anyone was facing any
imminent danger due to this movie
I'm still really skeptical about North
Korea being behind the hack but one
thing that I will say you know just
commenting on Ben's commentary uh
there's something really admirable about
people saying you know what we made a
decision the decision was wrong and
we've changed our minds
but instead people want to pretend as
though they were on the right course
from the very beginning they weren't on
the right course okay they totally
wussed out they deleted all social media
accounts that were related to the
interview they canceled all screenings
they canceled all interviews at James
Franco and Seth Rogen were supposed to
do James Franco so you could get down
you gone he's gone that's it so now Dave
Franco we don't know Italy nobody okay
right yeah um do you think Mary so
forgetting conspiracy I'll go with your
no conspiracy fine however do you think
that there this was like a little test
for the industry at least of going up
maybe we start doing this simultaneous
YouTube streaming thing with less
theaters you know like some shift in how
they operate they'll certainly be
interested in and and how this does and
then they have to factor in how this
does related to you know how much hype
was there a lot of people you to guys
guess weren't planning on seeing the
movie I saw it you know I've seen I've
seen it yeah well but I mean nobody else
in America is more than 10 minutes in
right now let me tell you exactly what
happened
yeah well that was incredible I got a
guy that with the man thank you
uh uh it's pretty funny it's a little
stupid um it goes too far at times I
think James Franco is the weak link in
it just because that sort of Ron
Burgundy like character it needed to be
a little more or maybe a little less but
he was sort of in between on buffoonery
and it doesn't doesn't work but Seth
Rogen's pretty good it's a kind of an
interesting it's funny it's funny they
made a comedy they make basically good
comedies and this is this is this is one
of them I think that that when you see
it you realize that this was the
touchstone for sort of standing up for
artistic freedom that's gonna strike
people as a little puzzling that this
was where we got there funny guys and
they made a pretty funny movie yeah so
final thought on this to your point you
kind of think that cyber war is scarier
than real
or better thing like I'm not worried
that anyone's gonna hit us with a
missile I'm really not pretty much
nobody shooting a missile at us but
there was like a 24-hour window where
really seemed like we were taking away
our own freedoms because of a cyber
threat yes that does seem scarier the
issue with hackers is a serious one and
regardless of where the hackers are from
I don't know if they're from North Korea
or from the United States or some other
country it is scary to know that if you
have lacks cyber security hackers can
get into your personal email account and
leak all sorts of embarrassing things
right so we have an issue with the
government spying on us but we also have
an issue with you know random private
citizens that have access to all this
personal data what are they gonna do
with that data and a lot of those emails
that were leaked to the press were super
sensitive super embarrassing and I'm
sure that alone really freaked Sony out
which is why they made their initial
decision not to screen the right isn't
that the grossest part of this though
that these hackers whether you're for
hacking or not or anonymous all that's
up or not these were private emails that
those people were sending like we don't
want our private emails hacked into so
what do you make of the like the sites
like Gawker and everything that were
just publishing all the emails I had a
moment yesterday where I got into the
rabbit hole of it by the way Randall
Park replaced Kim jong-un he's the he's
extremely funny yes but yeah so uh I got
but I got into that rabbit hole and I
was actually on Gawker about sort of the
the Scott Rudin Angelina Jolie yeah and
I got caught up in that and you start
reading the emails and of course it's
interesting at first to read private
emails of people in powerful positions
and it's like they're playing out a
scene from a movie about the industry
like if we people really talk but
they're really talking this way sort of
how you'd write it and then you realize
I but about 17 minutes and there's one
story after another there's constantly
more you can read and is you know and as
a Angelina Jolie really sort of
self-obsessed and and egotistical and
maniacal and her desire to get Cleopatra
made and the big fight is gonna make
Cleopatra or the Steve Jobs movie which
one's David that you're gonna do it so
exciting yeah and then you're like wow I
know I don't care I don't care and I
don't care not because I'm smarter than
this I'm interested in the industry I
don't care because it felt Korean in the
wrong way it felt like watching amateur
poor not the good kind of amateur porn
but latent porn secret porn right hey
this person is they didn't mean for me
to see this and I don't even know
whether they believe it but we see it
written and then in a story on official
site and we assume it's what they
believe rather than what they're saying
to the person they're emailing in order
to get them to come around to their
point of view so it's you know Angelina
Jolie doesn't need our help
but it felt unfair right her so actual
last points isn't that like where we
should be sort of angry is sort of at
the Gawker's of this like I get it and I
think you make a really good point that
people write things in emails that
aren't exactly first up it's not for
public consumption but it's also not
always indicative of exactly I don't
feel and you're playing a little game or
whatever um so the companies and all the
websites that release the emails they
almost seem like the worst part of this
in a weird way yeah I mean I actually
have a lot of remorse because we covered
one of the email exchanges on The Young
Turks and I don't know why I had that
lapse of judgment but I did but that was
the wrong thing to do this is stolen
information stolen data stolen emails
and you shouldn't report on it if your
research you see and all that so I get I
get reportable yeah yeah yeah makes news
judgment each time and if in those
emails the ones you're talking about and
when I was on that show with you and we
took that video down and we disagreed a
little but it's funny at the end of that
video annals like I'm done with the
story like I'm tired of talking about
would you actually take the video down
yeah we took it down really interesting
it wasn't like we had some compelling
conversation that America needed to hear
anyway but not but nonetheless that was
that that was the right thing to do but
like there's a point at which we
wouldn't have taken it down and they
this was the conversation where they
were sort of you know talk about what
movies the president would like because
he was black an embarrassing moment I
don't think it rises to much of a level
of racism I don't think it's
demonstrative of anything except a a
poorly exposed email chain um but you
know but that said if they'd use the
n-word we wouldn't take the video down
right so you know and Donald sterling
crossed some line where we thought yeah
that was a private conversation but this
becomes relevant so you know we there is
a point at which these stories become
newsworthy into a country that these
guys have marketed and marketed Marcus
and told us what we should like and toll
but we should spend our money on and
then they get caught a little bit well
there's some newsworthiness to that but
I'm basically with you is that it felt
it felt wrong but I can't get on
everybody there's news there and and how
it came out as is I'm not sure they
should be they should be obsessed with
by the way I just did a search and I
typed in the and the interview on Google
that's that's pretty umbrella CLE if I
know anything about YouTube it's that
whoever is even paying for this thing is
going to watch about twenty seconds of
it not even get through the initial
credits and start watching porn so they